la administración de obama heredó la
peor crisis económica desde la gran
depresión la de la industria automotriz
que estaba a punto de colapsar un millón
de empleados estaban en juego pero el
presidente obama y el vicepresidente
biden no perdieron el tiempo culpando a
la gente o evitando su responsabilidad
se pusieron a trabajar se unieron a los
sindicatos ya las empresas y salvaron
esa industria automotriz
quién lo diría aún hace unos cuantos
meses a medida que comenzamos a cómo
luchar contra kobe
los trabajadores de esta industria se
pusieron en acción y comenzaron a hacer
equipo de protección para los médicos y
para las enfermeras vengan permítanme
explicar al presidente obama y el
vicepresidente piden salvaron las formas
de vida de estas personas y ellos
después hicieron su parte para salvar
vidas estadounidenses
esa es la historia de esta gran nación y
la acción lleva a más acción el progreso
lleva a más progreso y cuando trabajamos
juntos podemos cumplir cualquier cosa
después de todo la democracia es un
deporte de equipos especialmente ahora
es crucial que nos unamos para luchar
contra este virus y reconstruir mejor
nuestra economía nosotros tomamos esta
pandemia desde el principio muy en serio
en michigan escuchamos a los expertos
planeamos y con el trabajo de los
trabajadores de la industria y con poco
trabajo de la casa blanca ejecutamos un
plan salvando miles de vidas
solamente imaginen si hubiésemos tenido
una estrategia nacional para que
cualquier persona que necesite una
prueba pueda obtener la gratis para que
la gente pueda acceder a una vacuna para
que los educadores puedan volver a las
escuelas
by de níjar is en la casa blanca lo
tendremos by de níjar es van a liderar
con el ejemplo será la ciencia no la
política o el ego la que va a liderar a
guiar sus decisiones ellos saben que la
salud de la gente va de la mano con una
economía fuerte y saben que la acción
lleva a más acción en los últimos meses
hemos aprendido que es lo esencial
levantarse entre los retos no negar los
hemos aprendido quién es esencial
también no solamente los ricos no
solamente un presidente que prefiere
luchar contra los estadounidenses que
contra el virus es la gente que pone su
propia salud en riesgo para cuidar al
resto de nosotros ellos son los
importantes luz
médicos los los camioneros los
profesores las enfermeras los que llevan
al correo y los trabajadores de la
industria automotriz así que estas
personas muchas personas han perdido su
vida por el cobre
más de 170 mil personas en el país han
muerto en el país incluyendo una niña de
5 años de visión llamada de skype cuya
madre es una oficial de policía y su
padre eres un bombero en el es otra
generación nos hemos definido por lo que
hacemos o lo que hemos fallado en hacer
entonces por skyler por sus padres y en
la memoria de todos aquellos que hemos
perdido actuemos tenemos como una sola
nación
encontremos la fortaleza para hacer el
trabajo necesario